(ballroom music)
(DJ yells)
- [Male Narrator] This is ballroom.
No, not the classical
dances like waltz and tango.
This is an underground scene
that's been a safe space of expression
for gay and trans people of color
for decades.
(DJ yells)
It's kinda like a mix between
a dance floor and a cat walk.
(strong bass music)
And this scene has created a whole
new form of music.
- Yeah, I'm usually like super
afraid of cameras.
- [Female Narrator] MikeQ is a touring DJ
who has been producing ballroom tracks for
more than a decade and is the founder
of the record label Qween Beat.
- I kinda feel like I'm talking to Diddy.
(MikeQ laughs)
Like, created the first record
label in ballroom music.
So we're here in New
York to meet the dancers
and musicians of the ballroom scene.
And this week is special because it marks
the 50th anniversary
for the stonewall riots.
- [Female Narrator] Which
was a 1969 uprising of
gay and trans people
that that took the fight
for LGBTQ rights to the mainstream.
- [Male Narrator] Since before stonewall,
the ballroom scene has provided a place
for the most marginalized people
in American society could feel
a sense of community and explore
performances of gender and sexuality.
Black and Latino, gay and trans people
gather to walk or compete at balls.
Contestants strut down makeshift runways
wearing glamorous fashions.
Voguing with its angular model inspired
dance moves became a part of these runway
walks in the 80's.
Participants vie for titles like
most real, best schoolgirl look,
best military look.
And sometimes they are part of a house
or a family, like House of Ninja,
House of LaBeija, or House of Xtravaganza.
- [Female Narrator] For
many, a house provides
a surrogate family when their real one
has disowned them.
Each house has a mother and father
who provide mentorship for their children.
- To be part of a house,
to be part of Xtravaganza,
was family and looking out for each other.
Looking out for our own.
Defending our own.
I am honored to even be here today to call
myself a father of such
a beautiful organization.
Jose Xtravaganza is the father
of the House of Xtravaganza.
He's been a part of the ballroom scene
since the 1980's.
- I was 16 years old
when first heard about
the ballroom scene and waltzed down here,
as a matter of fact.
And so a whole, like, utopia of world.
But see, as fathers when
the voguing comes to play,
I go back to where it's from.
Voguing is a feeling, it's an attitude.
It's self expression as individuals.
- [Female Narrator] Vogue is just one
part of walking, but it might be
the most well known.
Named after the fashion magazine,
voguing was introduced to the mainstream
in 1990 when Madonna
released her track "Vogue".
It was the dance style
that inspired the song,
not the other way around.
And when Madonna needed
a vogue expert she turned
to Jose Xtravaganza who choreographed
and appeared in the
music video for the song.
- [Jose Xtravaganza] It was
a dance that was created
on hope and dreams for
the community, you know?
It was a dance that, you know,
no technique was necessary.
You didn't have to study it at a school
like other art forms of dance, you know?
- [Female Narrator] At first, voguing
was all about locking the body into
perfectly straight lines and awkward
but visually stunning positions.
Kind of like the models in Vogue magazine.
Back then, this was done
to disco or house music.
So as a classical musician and just a
music appreciator in general,
I can, after hearing some ballroom tracks,
I can recognize the similarity.
The kinda vibe, the culture behind it.
But I can't quite put my
finger on what exactly
are the musical ingredients that go into
creating a ballroom track.
- [Male Narrator] A ballroom track.
- Could you break it down
and in your own words,
what is essential?
- The music started out
with just house music
that was adapted into ballroom
before we got our own music.
- [Female Narrator] The
most famous vogue track
of the 1980s was "Love
Is The Message" by MFSB.
But in the 1990s, "The Ha Dance" by
Masters at Work emerged
as a quintessential
vogue track and it's had
the ultimate sting power.
- That track itself is just important.
Like I said, it's just
music that was regular
house music that was
brought into ballroom.
- [Female Narrator]
MikeQ has said that 90%
of the tracks he's produced
have been Ha-ly mixes.
It's still considered the voguing song.
- This came out in what 1991?
- The Ha dance includes a few things that
make it so iconic, vogue worthy,
and representative of the genre.
Minimal lyrics that allow the commentator
to preside over all ball's proceedings.
Calling out categories
and pumping up the crowd.
(commentator yelling)
A cymbal crash on every fourth beat
that tells dancers when
to dip to the floor.
And of course, the samples.
- They were able to
catch that fourth beat,
that sound, which we call the Ha Crash.
- Okay.
- Can you explain that further?
(Ha music playing)
- So, you hear it?
One, two, three, four,
one, two, three, four.
- [Male Narrator] That
sample you hear throughout
the Ha Dance that iconic Ha
comes from "Trading Places".
A 1983 movie starring Eddy
Murphy and Dan Aykroyd.
(singing along to Ha music)
The film doesn't hold up
under modern scrutiny.
Aykroyd is in black face in this scene,
but the song immortalized and transformed
that moment into something for gay
and trans people of color.
- Though a lot of people think,
oh you know sample the Ha, and there's
just a Ha crash in there
and there's ballroom.
But that's not it,
there's still that feeling
that it has to embody
and I think you can only
get that from visiting a ball
and being, you know,
immersed in the culture
and seeing how it is and feeling it.
(car engine sound)
- [Female Narrator]
MikeQ invited us to his
monthly party House of
Vogue, so that we could
experience the ballroom scene ourselves.
We wanted to learn how
ballroom music has evolved
from the early disco tracks
and when we got there,
they were pretty excited to
have PBS in the building.
(ballroom music playing)
- PBS kids, got art?
PBS kids, got art?
Ladies and gentlemen, PBS
is in the mother building.
(audience cheers)
Got art?
PBS kids, got art?
I'm being interviewed by
the legendary iconic PBS.
(laughing)
(bass heavy music)
- If you'd to pinpoint the hallmark
sounds of ballroom music,
what would that be?
- The hallmark sounds in ballroom music.
I would have to say the
number one is the crash.
- It's not like a regular drum crash.
They like warp them, amplify them.
It's like (makes crashing noise).
You're like, whoa!
- It's extra.
- It sound like the matrix.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
(loud bass beating)
Are you the sample?
This is cool!
- And wait till the crash come in.
(singing along to song)
That's that Jersey club I'm all about.
(ballroom music)
- [Male Narrator] Today's
ballroom tracks are a
mixture of disco, funk,
hip hop, house, R&B,
and electronic music.
- [MikeQ] DJ Vjuan Allur, he came up
and started making remixes,
like actual remixes.
So he would take from all
those older house tracks
and what not, and put into his remixes.
So that's kinda where the formula started.
- [Male Narrator] The repetitive
bass beats and the cymbal
crashes tell dancers when to strike a pose
or hit the floor.
(ballroom music)
- [Male Narrator]
There's something special
about the collaboration
with you and MikeQ,
can you talk about that?
- He's a genius, like honestly
this has not been in ballroom,
like there's not too many DJs
that can connect with a performer.
Like, you can put anything hot out there.
You can vogue to it, but if the beat don't
connect to what you're giving, you're not
gonna get that cool story.
- [Male Narrator] I was gonna ask you
if you could like show us
where you get your sounds from.
Your favorite 808's, this and then other.
I only ask this so I can
steal your techniques so.
(repetitive sounds)
- So what I do first is,
because I have a long
process the way that I do stuff.
So I will create loops at first,
and fruity loops here.
- [Male Narrator] Okay, so you plug in.
Okay, okay.
- [MikeQ] Yeah, I get my
samples and I plug them in.
Just this way.
- [Male Narrator] So
they're in increments,
it's like 16th notes.
One and a two and a three, across the top.
You know what I'm saying,
like in groups of four?
One and a two and a three and a four.
So each of these instruments
is triggered at different 16th.
- Oh.
- You see what I'm saying?
- I've never seen something like this.
- After that, just start adding.
You know, I'll just add little elements
whatever I hear, like in my head,
I'll picture people voguing a lot.
- [Male Narrator] Work, yeah, yeah.
- Or just like through the art of voguing
or being at a ball, that's
what I'm thinking about
when I'm making tracks.
(ballroom music)
- One word that we kinda
agreed on in the car
is ballroom music has
an unmatched attitude.
If there was a big word,
I would just say attitude.
- [MikeQ] Okay, I like that.
- [Male Narrator] I would say attitude.
- [Female Narrator] Attitude, very catchy,
very fun, and relaxed but intense.
- Ballroom tracks are meant
to inspire competition.
They're meant to make you feel
fierce when you hear them.
Like you're about to do a
battle on the dance floor.
That's because voguing
started as a way to work out
differences between rivals.
In "Paris Is Burning"
Willi Ninja, known as the
godfather of voguing,
says that when two or more
people are voguing on the dance floor,
whoever had the best moves
was throwing the best shade.
- Sometimes people throw
shade just by voguing,
like say you're at LSS if I call out LA
that LA come out and show who he is
and you just pop up like, oh!
(laughs)
- Okay!
- Like, bye!
That's throwing shade.
- That's shade!
- [Female Narrator] And when
you throw shade is that always
a negative thing or is
that kind of a sign?
- [Ash B] You know what I
had to learn in the ballroom
I had to grow tough skin
because I'm from the hood,
so people throwing shade
to me kinda feel like,
yo you coming at me?
It's like, yo why you coming at me?
But I realized it's
really like sportsmanship.
It's like playing basketball
and somebody smack you
on the butt, like it
comes with the territory.
- The tracks are also meant
to encourage and celebrate
trans femininity.
Some of the most classic
ballroom tracks include samples
that have phrases and words in them
that might be offensive
to the average listener,
but at a ball it's high praise.
Music is a reminder of the
enduring length between
the dance form and the
performance of femininity.
- I want you to explain
the word (meowing).
- You, you look masculine as hell.
But if you go to vogue and
you so soft and elegant
with it, it's like who
she's feeling (meowing).
You know, it's like she is.
It's because you're
feeling your femininity.
- So usually when I say (meowing)
it's usually just pertaining to the vogue.
Or, oh I'm feeling like,
use it as a, you know,
kinda like a feeling.
- Oh she's (meowing) that means...
- You're Michael Jordan.
- Yo, no it don't even mean, it means
yeah you could say Michael Jordan.
But no, we're gonna say you're like RuPaul
and Dennis Rodman.
- Wooh!
(ballroom music)
- [Male Narrator] Ballroom may still be an
underground, underappreciated subculture,
but we see it's influence everywhere.
In fashion, to movies, to TV.
Even the way we talk.
- Yas, queen!
Yas, queen!
- The shade, the shade!
- [Female Narrator] What
about some things that you
could think of that people
commonly misunderstand
or, yeah, just misunderstand
about ballroom?
- Okay, so the number
one thing, the thing that
popped in my head, is like everyone
they like to call the dip
they call that the death drop.
The death drop or the shablam,
which I don't know where
they got that from.
Yeah that's like one big thing
that we have a problem with.
- So it's no shablam?
Okay, so it's called the dip.
- It's called the dip.
- Not the death drop, okay?
You heard it from MikeQ here first.
Let's get it.
- It's not called the death
drop it's called the dip.
(ballroom music)
- [Male Narrator] While the scene becomes
part of pop culture, these
artists are making sure
ballroom stays true to it's origins.
A celebration of gay and
trans people of color
by creating music that is
distinctively their own.
- [MikeQ] I just don't
want to be exploited in
such a way where
everyone's like so into it
all at one time and then
next year no one cares.
- [Male Narrator] Right,
like a trend or fad or
something?
- [MikeQ] Yeah, but it's
not that because it's like
so many people put their
like lives into this and
you know, it's like
everything for some people
including myself.